let's give a round of applause the team
won hi so welcome to t1 and I introduced
us really quick we have Johannes we have
Stefan we have Morgan and I'm Katharine
and I'm going to start by telling you a
little story so when I found out I was
accepted to Eddie design shop I started
jumping up and down because I was so
excited to come here because I had a
huge problem I am an educator of an
educator for 25 years history teacher I
thought fourth grade teacher for 12
years media literacy specialist and
brand new director of academic
technology and in my interview for my
brand new job my boss said can you build
me a Fablab I said fantastic all right
you need to teach engineering and you
need to get the Fab Lab up and running
I'm a history person I have no
engineering background where do i go for
resources and art company one vision is
going to solve that problem it's going
to give me curriculum it's going to give
me training and it's going to give me a
community of professionals and teachers
to help us move forward awesome so when
Catherine guy here we really wanted to
find a way that we could help her out as
much as possible kind of going on those
three topics you talked about curriculum
that support group from the community
and then the resources in your community
so our solution was to have a mobile
engineering bus that really focuses on
teacher development there's a lot of
programs out there that look at you know
um for example at my school the local
science museum would come into
experiments and it was great and
inspiring and everything but then they
left and they were gone and we forgot
because well there is nothing left to do
so what we have here is that our program
is that we have a online site a portal
that has all this information for
student for teachers then this our team
teak pairs of teachers and students they
work together in professional
development they test it out here in
this section where the students and the
teachers are in action and then when the
teachers leave they're still able to
access this information via a portal
that we've created online that um we
actually have right here running
so yep okay well not really haha it's
cool thanks so much so two minutes of
questions judges seem to can I have you
come up to this side of the room and can
we have any clarifying questions for
team one please did I neither it was a
bust yeah the idea was that it would be
an engineering adventure sort of truck
plastic but really that's just the
vehicle for mechanism um to transport
our community of experts of mentors of
you know rock star high schoolers who
would inspire kids and then also the
people with the knowledge to inspire
teachers as well and bring resources
because I'm from a place in Ohio that
you know it's not Boston it's not San
Francisco we don't have huge tech we
have lots of resources but maybe people
don't know so that would be one thing
that our group would really work on is
when you're when our team is there they
would look around they talk to your
community and figure out what resources
they can help pair you up with can you
please clarify some dissemination
tactics I know well one of the things
that you do is a lot of outreach we can
have we would go to conferences we would
have direct mailing to schools we would
work with professional organizations and
we would get partnerships we'd like the
engineering society and and outreach
that way and also because we have this
great online portal we can also share
these resources through places that
people already share things so if we
have great engineering projects put them
on instructables we find code put it on
sourceforge pinterest I mean there's
lots of projects there yeah and how many
buses are guys like
what are the sense of scale you guys are
thinking about is there one for teacher
per school or so realistically we need
to scale up over time the idea was that
within two we'd have one year of kind of
planning gathering resources and the
idea would then be to start with about a
small group like maybe a couple buses
and try and hit a region of the United
States take for example the Midwest are
a little bit farther west where we're
not near one of those innovation hubs
then as information spreads about our
program partnerships would be really
would increase and then we'd be able to
spread even more looking about some of
the obstacles and how you'll overcome
them